oh I'm sorry the old Katie can't come to
the phone right now
she's dead hey guys Katie Krause here
and I'm in Santa Monica outsides a
reputation pop-up store it is opening
day and AT&T and Taylor Swift are giving
80 and all access pass are you ready
[Applause]
tailors pop up is part of a multi-year
deal with AT&T and is located at Santa
Monica's 3rd Street Promenade so I got
in line yesterday so Monday at 8 p.m.
literally the line was completely empty
I was like here I'm gonna say I'm not
gonna move is it everything that you
dreamed it would be everything and more
everything yes yes everything and more
how many people does it take to put
together this pop-up shop there's many
people behind the scenes working on this
for many months how instrumental is
Taylor Swift in this process all very
Anna the journey continues right it's
the journey of Taylor Swift now on the
making of a song it all continues
it doesn't stop now the Grand Tour one
question are you ready
inside you can check out key staples
from her music videos like the look what
you made me do throne and the birdcage a
new edition the New York pop up didn't
tap the LA location also features this
Hollywood inspired reputation wall and
this custom la snake keychain
there's only 250 of them available I
think that's what we wanted to bring
that a little personal souvenir for LA
so people can walk away with do you know
how many cat mannequins are in here 10
10 to 12
it was style then we have an independent
specialist that comes along with us for
the tour she sucked such great art that
she puts on all these mannequins you can
also watch all the episodes of her
series at the making of a song in the
lounge while enjoying cookies and
refreshments and let me tell you the
Swifty's will be out in full force
through the weekend what is about Taylor
that you think resonates with so many
people I think it's just like her lyrics
there's just a personal and you know
Taylor Steve is like our popular number
generation it's also Taylor's birthday
week
happy birthday dear Taylor
if you could get her anything in the
world what would it be happiness forever
that's so sweet
privacy's hopefully like a year of just
peace with her and her boyfriends
dumping cat related hopefully de leurs
la pop-up shop runs through December
16th
[Music]
you